[Music]
the ratio is probably water to the
combined cement ash right that is what
you're doing is you're making a new
cement by mixing action
this semester I'm co-teaching a class
that we call D lab schools and we're
focusing on the design of better schools
that lower cost if we can reduce the
cost of of a standard government school
then they can build more schools and
lift more families out of poverty
through education we're focusing on
Cambodia where a brutal regime in the
1970s basically wiped out an educated
class in Cambodia educational materials
and so there's a tremendous need for
better schools and for learning
materials so it's almost certain that
the ash in Cambodia is coarser than this
yes but this is what's gonna make better
concrete at lower cost and gonna help
build more schools you know this class
is about technology and implementation
of technology but fundamentally it it is
about public service it's about how do
you bring your MIT education to bear on
vital problems facing the world and how
do you make the world better one in my
tea class at the time and this ethos of
public service is one that's manifested
itself in many different ways over the
first 150 years of MIT when William
Barton Rogers founds MIT he has a
wonderful vision for a new kind of
educational institution it's based on
the principle that the laboratory is as
important as the lecture hall
safe drinking water it's one of the
great luxuries here in the United States
and the person we owe much of that to is
Ellen swallow Richards she was the first
woman to graduate from MIT
she taught sanitary chemistry but what
she's most famous for is a phenomenal
study of the quality of water in the
state of Massachusetts she collected
some 20,000 samples carefully
documenting the results she transformed
water quality standards for the nation
within a year Austrian Archduke Franz
Ferdinand was shot down and the greatest
war the world had known exploded in
Europe the United States entered World
War one a quite a bit later than most of
our European allies but when it entered
the war it was with great gusto and that
was true right here at MIT as well MIT
functioned primarily as a humongous
training ground there were first and
foremost the need for pilots remember
aircraft were actually quite a new
technology at that time at MIT jumped
into the lead in training aviators and
it turned out even more important than
pilots or mechanics engineers to design
improve and maintain those aircraft
here's a great photo of three MIT
students with some early radio equipment
this I think dates from around 1918 this
one's one of my favorites it shows a
tank rolling down Arlington Street it
says first American tank made in
technology
here we see a number of fresh officers
MIT had run a massive officer training
program during the first world war one
of the alumni from that program composed
a song called the flight song says
flight a flight a here at the Institute
studying Aeronautics under Mac Ark
working loot and when we get to the Kiel
Canal will do the job up neat Oh Hans Oh
fritz they'll be no German fleet alas
ensign McClellan who composed that song
a perished himself in an airplane
accident in France early in 1918
[Music]
December 7th 1941 a day of infamy even
as Japanese diplomats were conferring
the Secretary of State hull on piece
measures Nipponese planes were swooping
down on Pearl Harbor
the battleship Arizona was completely
destroyed and four others severely
damaged just over 70 years ago it was
September 19th 1940 there was a
top-secret meeting in Washington DC was
actually in a hotel room and there were
a few people in attendance including mi
t--'s president Carl Compton and
crucially a British delegation as well
had adviser Henry Tizard the British
came carrying this it looked very
bizarre hard to imagine such amazing
consequences coming from such a tiny
little device it was called a cavity
magnetron it might not look like much
but of the people who received it at
night they came to call it the gift of
the gods with the United Kingdom deep in
the throes of the Second World War there
was simply no resources there to develop
this further for genuine wartime use and
so there was a deal being forged that
the British team would give this device
to their American colleagues in exchange
for a full-tilt effort to develop
centimeter wavelengths short short
wavelength radar with the hopes of that
would in fact turn the tide of the war
it was able to produce amazing output of
power and it meant that one could
actually see things that were much much
tinier they could be used to detect not
just massive hulking things like
aircraft but in fact tiny little
features like periscopes from the
perilous German u-boats as submarines
MIT was gearing up in a very major way
for national defense one of the largest
efforts would become known as the
radiation laboratory or the rad lab for
short
it became the Allied headquarters for
the entire effort in radar it just
massively and almost overnight
transformed MIT transformed relationship
of science technology in the military
and changed forever what we would know
as science in the service of the state
mi t--'s tradition of national service
continues to this day and this drive
that I'm doing now to the airport to
catch the airline shuttle to Washington
DC is one that I do not infrequently as
part of my job and it's a long tradition
at MIT MIT faculty have served as
presidential science advisors as
secretaries of the Air Force as heads of
the National Science Foundation and have
taken advisory roles in any number of
different agencies over the years and
it's a proud tradition at MIT and the
Institute supports it as part of our
work the 1930s an MIT professor named
Charles stark Draper began putting
scientific instruments into the cockpits
of aircraft and developed a lot of the
basic technology of what's now called
instrument flight
during the Second World War Draper's
laboratory called the instrumentation
lab grew very very large taking
techniques they had applied for
instrument flying to control gunfire
aboard Navy ships and helped the US Navy
fight off the kamikaze threat
[Music]
during the Cold War a lot of those
techniques developed into what's known
as inertial guidance which is the
ability to navigate by using gyroscopes
and accelerometers and in the 60s Draper
and his instrumentation lab really built
the guidance systems and the computers
that controlled the Apollo missions to
the moon indeed the very software that
literally flew the lunar landings along
with Neil Armstrong was written and
developed here at MIT by members of
Draper's instrumentation lab they asked
me if I could make the equipment that
would take them to the moon and back and
I think yes I could well I said how
would I guarantee this and I said I
would go along and run it myself
one of the lasting contributions of
Apollo was that picture that was sent
back that Christmas Eve of Earth rise
over the moon's horizon here was this
blue planet with white clouds looking
very fragile and indeed it is many
people feel that was the beginning of
the environmental movement
so while Apollo did reach out and take
us on a small step towards the Stars it
also had us look back and realize we
really had to devote a lot of attention
to protecting and preserving the planet
Earth I watched the Apollo 11 landing in
my den with my family when I was five
years old I remember very distinctly and
so it really inspired me to dream and
eventually become an aerospace engineer
and professor at MIT the current
students that I have the pleasure to
teach have some of the hardest
challenges in front of them in terms of
energy in terms of climate change in
terms of exploration the great news is
that they have passion they will rise to
the occasion they have all of the skills
I think we all came to MIT because we
knew that it was a place where we can
make a big difference and we all want to
make an impact in our field and solving
some of those really tough challenges
are things that get us up in the morning
the future generation it has this Apollo
moment right now so I really see the
symbiosis between the great challenges
of the world and what MIT can bring to
help solve and contribute to those great
problems
one of the things I think is great about
MIT is it's a place that believes in its
students and believed that their
students will do great work before they
graduate as well as after we're going to
Cambodia to implement some of the ideas
that students have worked so hard this
semester to develop so that's the
ultimate example of going from the
classroom directly into real-world
applications when we were in Cambodia we
had a chance to make some testings out
of concrete that incorporated the rice
husk ash we had found at local rice
mills so we loaded concrete beams with
soil bricks in a traditional three-point
bending test like you might perform in
your classes at MIT okay the
construction supervisor was actually
really impressed with how strong the
mortar was when he chipped into it not
only were we able to test out some of
our research but we also got to do
something really important for the
community
fifteen years ago as a graduate student
who thought that it would be nice if MIT
did a little more International
Development and now literally thousands
of students are going into the field and
they're really making a great difference
in the world this is a generation that
has a will to citizenship passion for
solving problems when they discover a
problem I mean no sooner have they
understood it's a problem they roll up
their sleeves to get to work I come to
call this generation generation why not
they are undaunted by the kinds of
challenges that we can you know list you
know by the world is such a tough place
now they they're just out there to make
the world a better place and I love this
idea that they emerge as someone who has
a passion but also compassion welcome to
our impromptu English class three four
five good job for coming here to MIT and
working with a public service center and
having these opportunities to be exposed
to the world around us and the need
around this has really yeah I mean it's
entrenched I feel like I wouldn't be
able to shake it off even if I wanted to
and this is not a new idea the notion
that we are in service to the world
through our work so that mission of MIT
the notion of public service as part of
our work as professors as students runs
through the Institute today and is a big
part of what makes MIT what it is
[Music]
you